part of the problem that we have here is
we keep indulging Russia and Putin the
people around him in their narratives of
History so be able to get to a
negotiating table get to some kind of
resolution we have to in a way
demilitarize this history we have to
push back against it because we have to
move forward if we keep going back into
history and making claims against other
countries and other peoples and other
regions I mean there really is no end to
this I mean I I grew up in northern
England where you know the Roman Empire
was so should we go back to Rome I mean
certainly predate you know a lot of
other English History the Romans were
there first you know kind of thing if
you if you start playing this out you
know so so we have to actually say look
no this is not going to work we cannot
have any kind of negotiation resolution
here that is basically satisfying one
group's view of History